and everyone and welcome back to you
people
today we connect with Roberto viola a
techie at the head of the digital
department of the European Commission
together we will browse a new digital
policies and see how decisions taken
today will affect your life tomorrow we
will also navigate his past pick up some
old phones and plug into satellites your
Wi-Fi is working your phone is fully
charged then let's begin
[Music]
I am delighted to welcome
Odessa Beulah the disease of the
European Commission something nice it's
four words and a half a day others that
has brain hard words for technology the
man who once gave powerful people a
headache is full of mysteries but one
thing is for sure for Becker's work
which shape to visit to work for the
next 20 years will you call yourself a
digital guru oh my god
I would say a digital savvy I've seen
pictures of a picture of you building a
computer in the 80 how come it was the
first computers the first computers the
personal computers coming on the market
and it was by common for the digital
gurus at that time to build their own
computers I became rather successful all
my family was asking for computer
friends I could have gone to the
business not that API can tell you I
mean the house was full of pieces of
computers memories and like six laughs
you know we could build a computer even
I didn't know that you buy them you
could do steel you can do it it's not
that common could you tell us in few
simple words what is the digital single
market oh it's a beautiful thing it's in
Europe you can move around and you don't
feel you're changing country you don't
pay roaming fees you are the same rules
for privacy you can shop online you have
you can watch your favorite movies
favorite sports how do you do with new
technologies because it's evolving all
the time so there's a balance I guess to
make between regulation and also letting
the technology blossom so how do you
keep this balance it's very difficult
and you have to keep this balance you
have to allow people to innovate to
really disrupt all the things and create
new one at the same time people need to
be protected there should be
transparency for the customers for the
people the rights of the people have to
respect privacy individuality so I mean
you have to keep always these fine
balance to make it understandable to two
people could you explain me in in one
sentence what it means
the key word I'm gonna say and what the
EU is doing okay so let's start with
Internet of Things well it's everything
connected to the Internet your fridge
that tells you by the milk is finished
do you have a fridge that is not here
not yet a building was doing you is
fostering this technology the
standardization the safety of these
things to make sure for its that your
own camera does is PI you and at the
same time is useful to protect your own
artificial intelligence well it's a
computer that can understand things from
many different data and things that are
happening around and gives you a
prediction of what is going to happen
and you in this field while the use may
do many things is basically introducing
artificial intelligence everywhere for
the benefit of the citizens so a
financing research and also love working
on ethics big data well it's a big 0 and
big one I'm joking big data is zillions
of data that we generate with our Smart
Watch smartphone sensors around and this
sea of data can be searched by
artificial intelligent machines and
allow you to understand much better how
things work geo blocking oh my god yes
but you filled it I'm sure
have you tried to shop online and at the
end the website says sorry I don't ship
your country's Christmas Oh I mean tried
to rent a car and you were redirected to
a website you didn't want to go these
are forms of geo blocking and you is
trying to prevent polished it's
abolished regulation that polish is Jo
blocking I mean from Christmas onwards
this Christmas people would be free to
shop online wherever
like and what happens if not if if
you're still geo blocked you still call
me okay so we're going to put the the
phone number of Soviet of you la here
cybersecurity it's protecting online
everything which has to do with the
moving data around and making sure that
people don't spy in your computer in
your smartphone
don't attack banks to attack hospitals
it's a very serious thing and fake news
we call it this information it's all the
attend to other equitable way of
representing information by people that
had not really good intentions can we
make the digital world ethical can we
apply the same rules that we have
offline but can we apply them online
absolutely I mean what applies offline
you should apply online so how you
behave online should be how you believe
offline people sometime they feel they
go online and they can insult other
people misbehave I mean I don't
understand why I mean you should be
ascetical as you are when you are a
human being when you are you use your
digital self
Oh better you remember your first mobile
phone we found it in the old drawer my
god you remember how long it took to
type a message and we were limited in
characters so I'd like to start with a
small challenge would you be able to
would you be able to draft the full
regulation of job looking in this small
iPhone Oh let's draft love the digital
single market okay I'm gonna do it on
mine and that's unfair we'll see maybe
you'll be quicker not sure so sure sir
shall we let's write let's try are you
ready ready start okay
I gotta correct as well
oh no but that's really unfair I'm done
done yeah I can tell it's really that
how is it to play with the phone quite a
challenge I must say more seriously you
were at the head of the European
telecommuters when mobile phone web
booming so how has this experience well
you know when I started to be a
regulator there were no smartphones
around no tablets still to connect to
the internet you had to use what they
were called dial-up modem you had to
dial up a number and they were making
kind of strange noises when you were
they were connecting couldn't connect
out to the Internet and at the same
times phone as well remember yes but so
what were you regulating in Anna at the
time was the beginning of it the most
important thing because we was the
introduction of 3G and then 4G and then
I mean deregulation or to allow cheap
prices to connect to the internet thanks
to the new rules by the way have some
question from the online audience about
phones so will you be ready to answer
some of our audience so we got Garrett
asking what does actually roaming mean
that's not a difficult one
roaming it's using your mobile phone
when you are outside your home coverage
your own country coverage and the you
did a lot to lower prices no zero prices
I mean when you are around in Europe you
don't pay a roaming fees anymore another
question from Yanni's Europe developed
the GSM standard as we said and today is
lagging behind Asia and the u.s. in
developing 5g networks is it too
bureaucratic to adapt to new
technologies look I mean 5g is not yet
started so let's give Europe a chance we
are working hard very hard I mean to
make sure and not in a non brokerage
I mean helping researchers have been
companies now to deploy very very
quickly 5g okay it's not only about
regulation it's also about innovation
it's a lot about innovation as well
a question from Gerhardt why can't you
up create tech giants it's a question
that we hear a lot tech giants like the
US or China you know I mean Europe as
many industrial giants it's fair to say
it woke up a bit late to the digital
revolution but now we are very serious
so stay tuned I would say say treants
where would you think the tech giant's
would be in which sector I would say
finest digital finance in robotics in
healthcare I'm sure there would be world
leaders they are already and they will
be digital world leaders an interesting
question that discovered why our mobile
phone bills much higher in the u.s. than
in Europe I would say a combination of
facto mostly in Europe you have more
competition no competition brings lower
prices as always
/ - I'd like to talk about your first
love space so you joined the European
Space Agency at the age of 25 yes did
you have the star wall syndrome
well probably the Apollo one because
when I saw the moon landing and I was 11
at that time I said that's something I
really you studied in that direction and
it was really your my would say my
generation really had a special love
with space most of you see I see you
brought us a nice miniature of the of a
satellite and it's it's Galileo what is
Galileo exactly well in a word it's the
European GPS it's a constellation
satellite that allows you to know where
you are and it's used for technologies
as well as it's used for mobile phone
but it's in mobile phones it's a bit it
will be a bit everywhere it's a new
generation of navigation satellites it
will be even more precise mm-hmm
why why should Europe have its own
satellites well first of all Europe
needs to have its own satellites because
they are used to watch football matches
what about these so we have a very good
coverage when it comes to satellite
television satellite telecommunication
now navigation satellites satellite the
watch the environment that's super
important to understand what's it's
happening whether I mean when there's a
natural disaster to have images to
understand so and to rescue I mean to
rescue people so in many many many
different ways satellites and permit
there's another important reason space
technology it's a sort of in the
frontrunner technology when you move
your foil you know that time in the
orientation changes that's called
gyroscope they were invented for space
or the touchscreen so all the new things
that you now use they were already used
20 years ago in space that's why I'm a
little bit digital save it now
because I have seen it all because of
this face
what is Europe's future in space so
what's the next step
do we go to Mass ready wait
we already went I mean but there are
many things to do many things to do I
mean the universe is big our earth needs
to be understood much better and also I
mean we need to continuously evolve
towards technology so thank you very
much for that thank you for connecting
you with us I have the impression we got
so many topics to cover that that's it's
never-ending discussion if we want we I
can have a tent here and we continue I
yeah exactly or we could do many
episodes if you wish
yes thank you everyone for watching you
can comment share online you can rewatch
the video but there is the last little
game we're gonna play with Roberto and
European movies so I suggest you click
on this link in this video it's a bonus
video for the rest thank you very much
for that oh thank you very glad cover
you
[Music]